the reason why I think it's important is
because I also want to recapture like
the little old lady very you know like
very simple person who says God will
take care of me because that's in that
mode it's like I actually don't know
what's going to happen
right I don't know what's going to
happen but I have a an orientation
something like I know that God wants the
best of me and the thing is that that
might mean that you're gonna get dragged
in the street and you're gonna get
killed and like all these horrible
things are going to happen to you but
that mode of anticipation is the best
mode to stand in in order to face
whatever horrible thing The Future Has
in front right and it's right and it's
not predictive that's right it's not at
all predictive it's just a stance which
is like all that is given will be taken
as the grace of God
foreign
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
how we do this is there a structure
probably not
usually in the YouTube situation there's
one person in charge because it's their
Channel yeah so it's like you kind of
know who's in charge of what
yeah there's always this at least
implicit
um
you see we're from Canada that's right
that's right
yeah
so so
um there was a question I mentioned to
you and Paul and perhaps we can start
there we don't have to stay there we
won't stay there yeah
um
so I picked up on your theme of
sacrifice Letting Go a kind of death as
being very very Central to coming into
right relationship with reality is that
a fair thesis at least one part yeah
good and then I took it and I I took it
into
a particular state of orientation
because if you maintain the orientation
you have towards all the beings or
um all the creatures if you want to use
more biblical language right that's not
the right or that's not the right stance
to be in relationship with being or the
ground and being Ultimate Reality
whatever God if that's fair enough I
think it and you can't use a thing to
think to come into right relationship
with no thickness
um and I I thought that thesis
was reasonably derivable from your
thesis
and I think you find I I'm not claiming
their equivalence because I don't want
to step on doctrinal toes but there's
significant uh similarities between
theosis and other states like that in
other traditions and you've acknowledged
that in the past so I don't think that's
a point where we get we get stuck or
anything but then it came to me
that that point
is intention and I hope it's tonos and
not just tension with something we were
also apparently all agreeing on which is
the the need for a significant Revival
reinventio of uh of ritual and symbol
and yet ritual and symbols seem to bind
us to creatures to things to particulars
and then there seems to be a tremendous
tension at least initially is that fair
oh no I think I think it's fair
um I think that
let me toss something in so we can kind
of have a few things going one of the
things that I was thinking about
yesterday when we were thinking about
the question of the origin
um the the past and the future yeah and
the notion of of how we exist between
the two yes uh and I I started real
because say maximus talks about the
logos as both the origin and the Telos
right they often the Omega right the
beginning and the end and and I I
started to realize that let's say If you
think about that image you have of the
campfire and they go out yeah when they
leave the campfire they're they're both
remembering the past and the future yes
right so the idea that you can remember
the future is very it's very important
because you do that every time
you're doing any task right if you're if
you're building something you're
remembering the future you're you're
always remembering what the the Telos is
but that Telos is the reason why you're
doing
the thing in the first place and so
the reason why I bring that up is of
course it reflects on the choices that I
made in trying to reawaken the kind of
let's say a more uh integrated vision of
the world is that I don't think we can
do it reinvent like I really don't think
we can reinvent in some ways our origin
is given to us right it's it comes like
I mentioned that yes it comes down from
heaven that sounds like a weird thing to
say but it it had we we're given
uh An Origin there are moments that
people participate in in origin moments
but you can't
it's a Kairos right you can't make that
up you know you you kind of it just
things just happen to be in this right
place at the right time with the right
people and then it's almost as you're
doing it you realize that now is a
there's an origin of something happening
um
yeah and so because of that I tend to go
back to
this is something that my brother
developed by the way if you everybody
probably knows knows about him but I
want to acknowledge that this idea came
from him he uses the
the the the Trope of
um promised land and Exile as a
structure to understand the bigger
meaning crisis that there seems to be in
the Bible a structure which is the place
where you find your home your identity
and uh communion and then a place where
that breaks and all of a sudden
things don't make sense you're in the
land of the Foreigner it's foreign Gods
you know you can't have cohesion and
what he does is he applies that to the
whole problem so the scientific
development the Scientific Revolution
the Enlightenment scientism and that
thinking is in some ways a
uh it's a moment of Exile but that so so
it's part of the bigger patterns like in
some ways I don't think it's not
something that hasn't happened before
Although our version is accelerated but
I see in history moments when this
breakdown and Exile happens and there it
seems like there are certain things that
you can do when you're in that moment
repent remember
um like Jonah right at the bottom of the
waters like remember the holy Place turn
turn reorient yourself towards that the
the origin which also becomes the the
Telos uh and so I think that explains a
little bit why and when I look at how
Christians did it when Christianity when
the world changed from the Roman Empire
to say to the Christian world
it wasn't as much a break as some people
want to represent it because in you can
see in Dante are the greatest example of
that in the way that Dante
formulated his Cosmic image he
integrated all the Romans myths with the
Christian story into a kind of synthesis
that was that was good okay so first of
all the on the initial point I don't use
the word invent or reinvent I use
inventio which is a Latin word which
means simultaneously to make ended and
to discover okay so it's it's a it's a
it's a verb of active participation not
of making yeah yeah it's it's right and
so I re-enter which to turn back to the
inventio place uh I and that's what I
meant earlier when I was talking about
dialectical logos there's practices you
can do but you can't make deal logos
yeah it's not an artifact right you
could do things you can just like a fire
you can make all the conditions uh that
increase the chances it will catch but
it has to catch of its own accord uh so
uh I'm I'm in complete agreement I think
at the first point
um that's why I'm I I'm very careful to
use that word rather than the English
word invent because invent especially in
America yeah that means this wait we
have this idea of innovation yes it's a
we have it's like our God this idea of
innovation no for so for me and that's
why I use I use more often the matter
the metaphor of befriending you can't
make somebody your friend but you it's
not like you're passive though like you
have to set yourself you have to orient
yourself you have to make yourself
available and then and then there's a
possibility that friendship will will
spark so first of all that's that's the
kind of thing I'm talking about there
second
um I think very much to understanding
this as a Kairos is right and um and
this is the next point is something I I
even independently worked on but DC
Schindler also talks a lot about in the
critique of pure reason is the idea of
synoptic integration the idea is uh and
and this is also counter current in a
big way believe me I know this because
we have we have we've had we've had
these two channels in the west and they
they they're superimposed on each other
which is bureaucratization and
specialization
um and like I mentioned last time
significant problem in Psychology like
do you think the people who did work on
meaning and life and and belonging we'd
talk to each other we'd talk to each
other and they don't right and so
um I think a way in which we're
Gathering the logs so that the fire can
spark is and this is what I do in
cognitive science and what I'm trying to
do even more broadly integrate with
trying to integrate with your work and a
very respectful in philia right and with
David David Schindler's work and Paul
and right is to achieve that state of uh
the broadest possible synoptic
integration that can make available I
think what you're talking about so yes
the Christians didn't just right and
that's what I also try and get with the
word steal the culture as opposed to
like make a revolution right like what
you're doing is you yeah it's you're
you're taking the logos ability to
gather things together so they belong
together so that you can give an account
and to which you are accountable all
that stuff and I'm trying I see that as
a project of like it simultaneously the
logos is spinning trying to get it to
spin out more and more and also try more
and more coalesce together in an
integration that that's very much the
project so there's a way in which in the
moment of Exile the moment of Exile
actually has an advantage it's hard to
understand it but if you look at the
stories in scripture Exile is the place
where you get riches Exile is the place
where your body grows yeah I thought you
said witches no it was weird
maybe you can if you gather a few of
those too but it's mostly the place
where you get you get you get riches and
so that's place where you increase your
body is the place to think about it and
you can think about it very simply right
when you're you're very coherent worlds
you starts to shatter yeah things start
to to grow too much and then they
disconnect from the origin but that also
adds possibility yes if you're ever
capable of reconnecting them then all of
a sudden Your Capacity is is so much
more because more is now connected to
the top yeah I think of Kairos
as the remember how at the level of
attention and then at the level of the
distributed cognition you have the
dispersal and variation and then you
have the selective return to to the
coalescing center yeah your brain is
doing that culture is doing that
and I think in Kairos what you're just
describing is exactly that you go into
the Wilderness you break the frame so
variation is now possible and then that
new variation gets drawn back in to
something and it's the TS Eliot poem we
return to the center after all of our
journeying and we know it again for the
first time like there's a sense of Sati
you remember it and you refit but you
also it's like when when people say it's
the animesis when people are in the the
when when Dia logos catches and people
say I've always been looking for this
but I didn't know what I was looking for
it's that it's the memory that's also a
discovery that's why for me I that's
what I'm trying to get with that word
inventia it's like oh I was always
looking for this but I didn't know kind
of thing
so so and I think what's what's
important at least for me because I
always complain about the modern world
everybody knows but there is a way
there's a way in which uh because one of
the problems we have is always that
there's a line of thinking there's a
line a philosophical line which tends to
see you know all manifestation or
variation as a kind of decomposition
yeah the idea that that it's immediately
evil because as soon as it moves into
variety that whole kind of Gnostic
strain but when if you understand that
the moving out into exile
actually has a function to then re
recapture or re or bring in more into
the pattern then all of a sudden the the
pattern of Exile and the idea of kind of
breaking home right or losing of
domicide even can if if reoriented
capture more of the of the world yeah
that's exactly it right right and so
that that that you know this the the
sort of maximal possible frame breaking
for the Mac maximal frame making like in
like like in a systemic Insight you know
sometimes you have like you have an
insight into like a problem and then you
have an insight into a set of problems
like like your relationship hasn't been
going right and it's not like you know
well how do I do the nine dot problem
it's like oh wait wait all of these
problems have this Nexus and if I
address this Nexus they all a systemic
Insight you know what I mean yeah and so
there's that that breaking and making
but my
the point I want to get at to bring it
back to the original point is what is
the most appropriate stance to maximal
frame breaking that will allow for the
metanoia return to the center and that's
what I was proposing this stance of the
most original orientation we have which
is this stance towards because this is
the stance that keeps
all the possibilities available but not
in a not not in they're not they're not
disoriented right and that's what I was
trying to get to this place what I was
talking about that I see at least shared
in theosis and Nirvana and Dao right
this place where right you are right
you've let go of trying to hold on to
like because as long as you're thinking
thinking in a thingy fashion you're
holding on to the framing that bounds
and makes them those kinds of things and
if you really are prepared you really
want to let go of the framing right you
have to let go of that way of thinking
you have to get to this original
orientation state in order to be at the
appropriate place on the horizon right
so that you can be open to what you're
talking about the the new possibilities
without giving up being oriented because
if you give up being oriented then
you're screwed because then you're just
tumbling through the nothingness right
does that make no I think that's exactly
what I that's exactly what I think the
the image that I that I have in Exodus
there's a that's exact seems to be
what's happening when Israel leaves
Egypt right it's breaking everything
breaking yeah yeah and they also leave
with a bunch of other people like other
people think like Israel left Egypt no
it says it was a mixed multitude it was
just a bunch of people who Israelites
all kinds of other people Riff Raff who
knows it was like this just this massive
in unformed thing that goes out into the
desert right that goes through the
waters the dyes that loses its previous
identity and then there's a process of
Covenant and of receiving law from above
and a re-establishing of hierarchy which
binds everything together some of it has
uh
some of it has a communion aspect to it
some of it has also a kind of cutting
off the the dead wood aspect of it which
is which is a harsher part but you can
kind of understand that I mean the
reason why I'm talking about this so
much is is that
is that I do have hope ultimately
because I sometimes Express a lot of
hopelessness but I really do have hope
that this story of even the meaning
crisis and the breakdown and everything
is necessarily leading to a higher
participation and to a big like a bigger
frame it's just that while it's
happening things are falling apart and a
lot of crazy Idols appear and all these
little Gods start to start to poke
through and want to get the attention
and want to take take it for themselves
but it seems like that
that that it in some ways like the I
even the even Christianity I've said
this before that the death of
Christianity seems to be part of how
it's going to happen I really don't know
how it's going back
sorry I really admire you saying that
because it takes guts to say that
especially when I presume there's a lot
of Christians here yeah but I don't mean
to stop being a Christian I just mean to
die and I'm not saying you are
I don't like saying that but you know no
no but first of all I I'm trying to
afford you a possibility uh to to frame
that a little bit more complete so
people can see
um
the positive intent behind the statement
and but because there's an analog to
what you're saying in the Exodus story
an entire generation has to die yeah an
entire generation has to die and Moses
can't go in to the promised land like
the leader and the entire generation
when it was just what what Caleb and
Joshua they get together yeah the Savior
and the dog right
because Caleb mean one of the
ingredients of Calvin's dog right he's
actually not an Israelite he's a he's a
canizite so it's like the out inside of
the outside like the the inner pillar
and the outer pillar are the ones that
create the new world it's a it's a
beautiful image actually it's kind of
painful to think about but but there is
and that reminds me um
let's make a straight you as an analogy
but it reminds me of Thomas Kuhn
um in the structure of scientific
revolutions and he talks about you know
when there's a paradigm shift and and
yeah and one of the one of the primary
mechanisms of paradigm shift is the
leaders of the previous Paradigm die
it's human mortality actually is one of
the facilitators of a paradigm shift in
science uh they have to they have to die
because you don't derive the new
paradigm it's like you're
idea of faith is leaping from one level
to another when you shift to Paradigm
you can make sense of the previous
Paradigm retrospectively but you can't
generate it prospectively and so there's
a there's a real death
um that makes possible a new generation
that creates the paradigm shift is does
that no I totally agree and I think that
that that's the image I think that when
we talk about eschatology eschatological
imagery it seems to be the way to
formulate it it's formulated as a crazy
image right yeah of a guy sitting on a
throne with a sword coming out of his
mouth and he's judging between what is
inside and outside and he's
re-establishing the law and it appears
almost mythologically but we know that
it's going to happen
because that's how the world works we uh
we know because we experience it at
little levels where things die and then
they they kind of come back up at at
higher in higher to higher
participations we also notice even not
just in time but in in the ontological
hierarchy itself how that works how for
things to participate in higher beings
they have to give up some of their
idiosyncrasy right like a like a family
meal like you have to give up your
idiosyncrasy to be able to commune with
everybody else or a sports team or
whatever and so the the mythological
image
in some ways it's like you're
formulating the print you're formulating
the pattern itself saying this is how
the world Works here's a here's a limit
version of it right and it has this this
imagery to it uh uh I want to make sure
I'm getting because I think this is a
crucial Point sorry so what I'm hearing
you saying is so this imagery is
obviously imaginal it's helping you to
become aware of things you're not
typically every day aware of and and
that awareness is sort of like of the
fundamental grammar of reality which is
what you need to drop back to when
you're in this space of the Wilderness
because that's that's All That Remains
is that sort of fun is that is well no
that's exactly exactly right but it
gives you a way because this is the
problem right it's like how do you
how do you live in the future how do you
Orient yourself towards the future the
future is not there yes just not there
yet you don't know what it's going to
look like but what you have is this
image this eschatological image and the
kind of mythological image of what the
future is and that makes it possible for
you to move towards re-enchantment or a
re-appropriation without knowing exactly
what that's going to look like in the in
the nitty-gritty details right right so
so this to me sounds like the way the
imaginal is at work in orientation so I
I don't know if I've
I can't remember where I've given this
this so this is based on a lot of work
by Hirshfield and others you go into a
um a university where at least the
people believe that they're the best
um in rational thinking and the use of
Education
um
and you present them with absolutely
clear argument and evidence that they
should start saving for their retirement
right now
you take all their challenges you
respond to it they all agree yes I
should start saving you come back in six
months and none of them are saving
for the retirement none of them
and then you do something else you say
okay uh what I want you to do is
well first of all let me see what the
problem is the problem is people don't
want to connect to their future self
because their future self is I mean I'm
facing retirement so this sort of looms
your future self is older uglier weaker
and unimportant
right
um and so instead what they did is they
said notice the language here I want you
to imagine that this isn't imaginable I
want you to imagine your future self
as a beloved family member that you've
always cared for and that you have and
you you and you have tremendous
compassion and concern for
when they come back in six months the
people are saving if they did the so the
variables are do they do the practice if
they do the practice they save and how
vividly they do the practice predicts
how much they save right this is what I
mean about how the imaginal is necessary
for the rational where the rational
doesn't mean the inferential because all
the inferences were there in the first
experiment what it means is the ratio
the orienting you and proportioning you
properly towards the future now that
doesn't mean they're getting an accurate
the point isn't isn't an accurate
prediction of their future self the
point is this ratio religio this proper
Orient properly proportioned orientation
is is that how these this is what I'm
hoping and and some people might not
understand why I'm harping up on this
because I do yeah because I want and I
think to me this is crucially important
at this moment is to is to be able to
formulate a form of eschatology which is
not fortune telling yes right which is
not like in so many years this this sign
is going to happen in and this and that
and this and that I'm not saying there
aren't signs and there aren't things
that happen but I think that that that
approaching the eschatology this way is
giving it can give us a solution because
people hear me and I know I freak people
out right I freak people out because I
talk about Ai and I compare it to the
beast in in Revelation and then people
think oh Jonathan is saying it's the end
of the world it's like I'm telling you
this is the this is the imaginal pattern
that was projected into an indefinite
future and eschatological future that
distills what civilization and
technology is and now I can look use
that as a model and I can look into the
world and I can see
instantiations approaching or moving
away from that model
so isn't it like a lens that allows you
to see better to the Horizon rather than
a model that you're looking at even no
it's like yeah it's a frame of it's like
a frame of vision that now permits you
then to look at the details of the world
and to be able to make sense of what's
going on so to me so when I say that I
really do believe that let's say AI is
moving towards the image of the beast in
Revelation uh and I can and it's not
just like uh how can I say this it's not
just like an arbitrary
description of something that I read in
the text that I can see oh it's this
like oh you put a note right when you
were young you probably had this thing
like they're going to put a number on
your hand and then as soon as someone
talks about tattoos they're you're like
oh that that's going to be it like
they're gonna put a number in the end
but it's like it's rather to understand
the imagery as something which is
manifesting the extreme limit of certain
aspects of reality and then they can
kind of come back and they can help us
understand but and the reason also why
I'm talking about this is because that's
what we at least in the Orthodox Church
that's the way it's set up so when you
look at an image of Jesus in an icon
you're looking at the eschatological
Jesus
even an icon a normal icon of Christ
when you see him with the book and his
hand that's Christ returning
that's that's the actual typology that
you have so you're looking at the future
when you're looking at an icon of the of
Christ like you're looking at the future
the eschatological future piercing in
but not predictively that's no not
exactly not predictively it's it's a
it's typological it's it's an image it's
man it's the it's the Divine man it's
all that and in some ways it's that's
what that's what's drawing us further
like drawing us into itself so the thing
about predictive is it gives you
cognitive closure that's why we seek it
in science and what you're talking about
this imaginal orientation this
eschatological is It's orienting to you
as a future but it's it's leaving space
for real emergence for Real uh
uncertainty right yeah because uh if no
one knows the hour when and yeah yeah
right and there's the example is right
everybody who's a Christian knows that
the person prophecy Elijah will come
before the Messiah
Ah that's a beautiful typological
understanding you understand what Elijah
did he kind of you know what his
function was how he kind of mocked the
the foreign Gods he cleared the the room
Jezebel died like that's okay all that's
going on and then Christ says Elijah is
John the Baptist
all right is anybody willing for that
kind of interpretation today like is
there are a lot of people capable of
doing that now where it's saying the
same thing now looking at the imagery
that is presented for example in
Revelation and not and just say oh
here's an instantiation of that
like this is the this is the Elijah
right this is the thing it's not it's
not a it's not a like I said it's not a
map a map in the the the gross sense
it's a map in the sense of uh of a frame
of of seeing yes so here I want to do
two things I'll try to do both as
quickly as possible one is I want to
give back to you how what how radical
your proposal is uh which I sometimes do
with you
uh because does it sound radical to you
guys uh I'm gonna try and make it more
radical I don't think so if you're gonna
make it more right no no no no it's it's
not radical in speech yeah okay that's
not what I that's not what I'm and
remember radical also means to return to
the origin point
radical return to the orange point so
you can reorient right that's the that's
the original meaning
um
just published a paper last year
integrating relevance realization
recursive relevance realization with
predictive processing Theory these are
two huge Frameworks
um there's two meta problems that you
have to solve to solve any problem one
is the relevance realization problem the
other is you want to as as much as
possible you want to anticipate rather
than react in fact you can sort of
measure the intelligence of a being by
the scope of its abilities to anticipate
and what your brain is it's a it's a
massive predicting machine uh uh at many
levels of abstraction predicting the
next second predict like it's doing all
of this in this really complex recursive
action I won't get into the uh the and
well I like surprises no well you like
surprises that are uh momentary failures
of prediction that increase your predict
your long-term prediction capability you
don't like absolutely uh irreversible
surprises those are horrible those
that's Terror right
um yeah you like surprise birthday
parties but if after surprise birthday
parties they pull out knives then you're
like no I didn't want that surprise
Okay so
I want I want people to really sink into
that to savor that I think this is an
incredibly plausible
um understanding
um
such that for example and this is this
comes into the heart of a lot of therapy
even
the brain prefers predictable
unhappiness over surprising happiness
and that's one of the ways in which
people get
some of your language perhaps I think
that's one of the ways in which people
can get bound into like sin right that
they can get locked in a kind of
unhappiness that they can't let go of
because of how it plugs into that I'm
not saying that's the theological
meaning so what I'm trying to get at is
to move into a mode in which because I
struggle against with this with
Scientists to move into a mode of
orientation where you are trying to
properly Orient to the future but not be
in the predictive frame it's radical it
goes to the okay fundamental guts of how
the brain is working does that yeah but
no but I think the
it's important is because I also want to
recapture like the little old lady very
you know like very simple person who
says you know uh God God will take care
of me
right that little statement okay because
that's that's in that mode it's like I
actually don't know what's going to
happen
I don't know what's going to happen but
I have a I have a an orientation which
is to say or something like I know that
God wants the best of me
and the thing is that that might mean
that you're going to get dragged in the
street and you're gonna get killed and
like all these horrible things are going
to happen to you but that mode of
of anticipation is the best mode to
stand in in order to face whatever
horrible thing The Future Has in front
of right and it's right and it's not
predictive that's right it's not at all
predictive it's just a stance which is
like all that is given will be taken as
the grace of God but do you understand
why I mean it's psychologically radical
take that stance because like I just
said yeah I don't do it I don't know
what to tell you I wish I did
I wish I did okay I know people that do
it more than I do so but
so there's there's one thing about the
stance from
the outward orientation and when about
the the taking up of The Stance one is
to not confuse uncertainty with risk so
one of the things we've we've convinced
ourselves is that we can capture all
uncertainty risk is calculable
unwanted things uncertainty is things
that can't be calculated and we have
tried since the enlightenment to
convince ourselves that we can capture
uncertainty with risk calculation and
what's coming out what's been coming out
in the history of physics and Science
and all kinds of things is you can't
translate uncertainty you can translate
some uncertainty into risk of course you
can right but there's a lot of
uncertainty if there's if there's real
emergence
then there's real uncertainty so first
of all that because one way we try and
seek is we we sort of people are placing
their bets yeah right right that's not
this you're not before the roulette
wheel that's not what's happening what
we're talking about here I'm really
trying to make this as radical as
possible and then on taking it up I
heard three things in you I heard these
three virtues humility trust and hope I
want to start with the one that I have
the most difficulty with and I don't
just mean philosophically I mean
personally which is Hope and first of
all because there's two interpretations
of Pandora's Box the standard
interpretation is you let all the demons
out but there's this thing in the bottom
hope right and that and that oh yes Hope
right that's that's sort of the standard
and then there's the heideggerian
interpretation is Hope is the heaviest
and worst thing in the Box yeah right
and when you take up it makes all the
others even more painful yes exactly
exactly it it it's a burden yeah um and
and we all know that there's obviously
toxic like the people who stay in
abusive relationships too long right the
people who misplace their hopes and the
fuhrer right all kinds of toxic versions
so perhaps we could so I want to talk
about all of them hope and humility and
trust but what like and I know hope is
one of the yeah I would say that again
it's the pro it's the idea of the proper
stance again that is what do you place
your hope in right because if you place
your hope in your spouse completely then
you're then you're going to lose
right if you place your hope in the
government in your school and whatever
and your friends if you put all of it
there then you're going to then it's not
going to work and I think that that's
why the idea of hoping in God which
sounds like a trite statement is
actually very profound in the in the
proper stance which is that the the my
hope is turned towards the towards the
infinite let's turn towards that no
thing which is beyond the things uh and
so but if I put my hope in this or that
leader or this or that
I'm I'm going to I'm going to ex I'm
going it's going to experience a
disappointment which is important the
disappointment actually it might be what
leads you towards hoping putting your
hope in the highest but if you look at
the in the Christian story you know
people I sorry if there are any like
Prosperity Gospel people here but it's
like in the early Saints they had their
hope in Christ and they were expressing
their hope in Christ as people were
chopping their head off like as people
were cutting their limbs off and ripping
their skins off their skin off it's like
okay that's a little that's crazy but in
a sense if you're in that situation
that seems to be the best thing it's
like a limited version of it right it's
like if you were in a situation where
someone's ripping your skin off what
would be the best
stance to have and the Saints
represented as this just look as high as
possible you know and that that it
doesn't make what's happening okay but
it's the best stance even in the worst
situation
this is good I'm gonna present something
to you as a foil am I making it as
Extreme as possible you should people
you should it's getting ripped off you
should you could no if we're if we're
preparing for an open Horizon making
moving to extremity is the proper stance
the proper way to comport ourselves to
what we're talking about so what do you
think that that idea of hope uh solves
the problem of Hope in terms of
disillusioned hope or or do you think it
could at least
well what I want to do is I want to I
want to try and get a clearer by the
contrast of foil uh and and this is
appropriate because this actually
happened historically
um because there's another response to
disappointment and of course crooked
guard plays these two responses off
against each other the night of faith in
the night of infinite resignation right
so there's the stoic response the stoic
response is look I totally get your
disappointment thing like 100 percent
agree right and so don't place your
heart in anything that was ultimately
disappointing and then they say well how
do we determine like in a rational
manner what's disappointing or not
because sometimes what you think is
disappointing may not but you can be
confused if you just go off subjective
feeling right so and then they say well
what you do is you try and put your
heart you try identify uh with what is
good
because if you are truly in relationship
to what is good you you can't ultimately
be disappointed and then they say well
what is it that's always good friendship
no friendship can turn bad and can
wealth no I mean you know Fame and they
rule and then they say what's the one
thing that's always good and their
answer is wisdom the cultivation of
wisdom is always good there's no
situation in which the Endeavor to
become wiser can turn like turns bad
wisdom is is the good and then that also
allows them because they did they also
famously faced torture and execution
with that now that's a different
different now I think one part of your
response is that's grounded in the
notion that the logos of wisdom is
ultimately oriented towards the logos of
being which gives them like so Seneca
says even when you're painted into a
corner you can jump into the sky right
that kind of thing so well there's a
reason why in at least in the Christian
tradition Christ is called the wisdom of
God yes the imagery of wisdom in the Old
Testament there's a duality to it a
little bit but MO most of the church
fathers interpreted that as being the
logos yes so what's and I'm so the
difference I would say between between
the stoic and the Christian would be
that in the in the stoic it's like it's
it's a virtue in the sense that it's a
it's a principle maybe yeah whereas in
the in Christianity it's uh it's it's a
person that you follow it's something
it's someone that you follow so so let
me see if I can strengthen your argument
yeah um and so part of what you're I
hear you saying given what we said
earlier and I and I'm I'm using you know
that I'm using the term in the sense of
Icon right
um
by saying it's personable is that the
the that there's there is something that
the that can give you afford the
imaginal engagement
that can reach your grandmother yeah
something like that is that is that it's
something it's something like that but
it's real it's not I don't know
and the imaginary the imaginary is not
real look
if predictive processing is right most
of your perception of this floor is
imaginal yeah right you're imagining it
but it's not illusory because the
imaginations are true right because
right because like if I want to walk
across this floor the sensory motor Loop
is too slow so my top-down processing is
actually predicting I'm imagining most
of the floor that gives me the capacity
to walk quickly across so that's when I
the imaginal is in the very guts of your
contact with reality that's how I'm
using the word is that is that okay no I
think that's fine I think that's fine so
the claim then is that and I'm getting
I'm understanding this claim better
because I've heard you and Paul make it
to me uh several times and each time it
goes around and I don't mean I'm just
playing with this I hope you don't think
that
I'm getting clear about what what what
what what the claim here is you know
Christianity has what stoicism has about
the logos to the logos to the logos and
that's what's always good and you can
you can you can align your logos to the
logos maximum
yeah so that's that's not not something
for it but what you're what you're
saying is in the form of a person and
not just a person but also hypostasis
yes and right um this hypostasis also
means substance in principle it's it's
we've reduced it to our lock-in notion
of what a person is but so it's a person
in this fatter sense is that is that
fair too okay and then that gives you
imaginal access to binding your logos to
the logos in an even more profound or
even relational in the sense that the
way that we experience and this is why
in some ways when we talk about
principalities or agency or
transpersonal agency is that the best
way to engage is with as if you're
engaging with an agency yeah not as if
you are right
as much as you're an agency right as
much as that that in some ways the mode
of human engagement is through agency
and through personhood like that's
actually how we we we engage uh and so
the the claim the claim is important
because it's there's a you know the
reason why
there's been so much uh kind of
arrogance about how silly the image of
God the personal God is and the kind of
how just trite and ridiculous it is but
I really I want to propose that
when we engage with
uh virtues even or with or with if we
engage with them as models and if it can
even incarnate models to follow that is
the that's the realist it's realer than
just engaging with it as an abstract
principle so it's like if I so that's
it's like it's an incarnational way of
thinking so I I follow examples of
wisdom yes and wisdom itself appears as
as a type of of uh of a of a agency that
I can submit my will to and so it had it
it changes the world back into a world
of
yeah I mean sorry it tastes the world
back into the more like the ancient
world where you have these agencies
which come down on us from heaven and
that we can follow and
we we don't we don't
see them as abstract principles or as as
forms in the way that Plato saw them but
more I think at least myself more like
the way that the pagans saw the gods
rather than the way that Plato saw sees
the forms well the neoplating is of
those two guests that's right no I
totally agree yeah so so
first I'm going to get you in trouble
again by saying things like that
the people that are like Jonathan the
superstitious guy trying to get John to
believe in demons or whatever I defended
you I defended you you did an amazing
job you know like someone started
attacking me and John was been amazing
at defending my position but I know it's
a radical thing and it's hard for people
to get into that that space because it's
a it's a it'll it's unsettling yeah but
if they don't leave the Paradigm they're
in to get to that space they're screwed
that's what's that's part of the AI
thing yeah it's part idea I think it is
part of the AI I think definitely but I
want to stick on this point because
there's two things so first of all
I'm I think I'm hearing you and there's
a way in which I deeply agree that
in order to properly Orient logos to
logos it can't just be the cognitive
grasp of a principle it has to be
internalizing the stage because you have
to be internalizing perspective taking
and identity formation is that is that's
exactly that's exactly right and so I
think and I I get that uh and and please
take this as how I'm understanding it
and I'm not drawing equivalencies here
but that's what I'm trying to do and
after Socrates is I'm trying to give
people uh Socrates as a sage that can
give them how to internalize
perspectives identity formation
basically you know embodies and enacts
because that's what Plato's that's the
point of the dialogue the point of the
dialogue is to say look there's no
definition of wisdom but here's a person
who embodies it and you and what the
dialogues do is they try to they break
you out of trying to come up with a
definition in order to find if if when
they work in order to orient towards a
weight here's an embodiment and I can do
exactly what you're talking about with
that now and I'm not I I don't want to
I'm not I don't want to do no no no no
but so I get I I get that right and I'm
not I can make it clear in the series
repeatedly I'm not trying to draw
equivalencies between Jesus and Socrates
although I think like in kirkegaard
putting in them into deep dialogue
that's
I think it's a very valuable thing to do
I I think now so big yes to that part
and so how can you so this is comes back
to what I said yesterday how can you do
that in a way that is more than just a
mental exercise so the reason why
yesterday one of the reasons why I
brought up celebration is because that's
part of it yes right so worship and
celebration in general is a way to part
to participate and make these things you
know it's like by just attending to them
and celebrating them lifting them up yes
you know I'm making them models for me
to follow and with with with
philosophers it seems difficult it's
difficult to do like unless you would
organize like a cult of Socrates which I
don't suggest and that's no no I'm not
I'm not suggesting that either well but
but it seems like that that that's in
some ways
that that's the that's the to me the
true mode of participation engages that
so it's like I you know I I and I
celebrate my father right it's like we
celebrate the 50th wedding anniversary
we're all there together and we're we're
there and we're recognizing that as
something to put up on the pedestal and
therefore to follow and to engage with
and it's more it's not the same it's
saying this is a good these are the
principles of a good marriage you know
you should follow them yes the uh the
first one is way more real because it it
has that you know it has exactly all
that it needs it has a kind of uh
liturgical aspect to it where I'm
lifting it up and I'm putting it up and
I'm saying to everybody look at this
this is what's valuable everybody looks
at my parents said they've been married
for 50 years and they're like wow look
at how that's crazy that they did that
you know maybe I could do that you know
I mean if we don't have those mental
it's not as explicit but that's how it
that's how it works yes yeah
okay so there's a there's
first of all an answer but before I
answer can I put my finger on the
problem I wanted to pose because the
answer will be engaged with that
so the problem you face
with everything all the good points you
just made this is why I wanted to push
on person is
our
are sort of established sense of person
is a creature is a thing and in
therefore so I put aside all the silly
oh God the sky wizard those people yeah
I agree they're they're by and large
sort of idiots because they're they're
right they're com they're they're
comparing the worst form of religion to
the best form of science which is like I
I can do that with science too like you
know here's Edison and he's an example
of Science and look at how crazy and
stupid his method is and the look at
reli and let's look at Aquinas and how
systematic he is see religion is so much
better than science it's so ridiculous
so I agree with putting all of that
aside but I do think there is a point
and right and I and I think the the you
know intellic makes this clear you know
the concern with idolatry is ultimately
the concern with right not relating to
the ground of being as a being right so
that's
the problem with the imaginal is it
focuses you in on a being yeah right and
yet and and I and I know Eastern
Orthodoxy really wrestled with this the
icon versus the idol and John Luke
Marion is are like but you see there's a
tension there right there's a tension
also with focusing on uh do you see that
no I I if unless I mean this is now I'm
going to be very very explicitly
Christian but
that if the being
if the being appears as someone who dies
uh and then that being appears as
someone who says something like you know
not me but the father right sure yeah
and so the the point the because you I
don't have a choice right that's that's
the problem you do have to see or you do
have to imagine you do have to but if
you do that and then that's what you
have right you have an image of a man on
a cross who's dying and he's doing it to
fulfill the will of the father and so
what he's what he's doing is showing how
it is a no thing when it appears as a
thing it appears as an emptying and it
appears as a kind of emptying of itself
into the world uh and so it it helps it
gives you that place of focus you've got
it but you know that
it's not how can I say that it is that
emptying and that it only exists in in
the in the the vertical relationship
okay now I can answer your question to
me then right
um because for me
I'm not proposing a cult of Socrates
because Socrates empties himself
completely and knowing that he does not
know and then what he does is he is a
way of imaginingly orienting to the good
or the one and that's the neoplatonic
interpretation of Socrates and that's
how I internalize Socrates as a sage I'm
not trying to build a cult around
properties
and so then let's say the practices
around Socrates like the lecture Divina
I imagine yeah yeah
for very much philosophical
contemplation but it's Socrates broadly
construed it's Socrates is the Exemplar
of philosophy as the cultivation the
love the the phylia the shared love of
wisdom which is always good
yeah well I mean it's that it definitely
shows the different like that's the
difference I guess like that's the
that's the the big divide is that in
some ways I think that we do need a cult
yes like we actually need it like
without it like without the cult we just
we we you know it it's not enough to
hold all the levels together because
what occult does sorry for asking me to
be radical like okay so with the what
the cult does is that because it frames
it in with imaginal language it makes it
accessible to everybody right so it's
like the most uneducated person can look
at a a crucifix yeah and the and the
genius in the University can look at the
same image and they're both engaging
with it at their appropriate level of
understanding it of participation but
but it it offers that possibility right
to all come together you know and so the
little lady can have a cross in their
house so totally fine and you and Paul
make this argument and you know that I
take your argument seriously and take
them to heart
um
I guess there's a little bit of pushback
yeah you should because I just had a
bunch of crazy stuff
uh okay just imagine all the comments
Jonathan says it has to be a cult
so first of all like I said yesterday I
think the accusation of a cult
um is just
empty uh I think if you re-center cult
in cultivation and the cultivating of a
sense of the Sacred then I agree but I
these practices that I'm talking about
do that
um
uh
but I want to be I mean the the the
accessibility scaling problem is is a
real I mean I've I've been responding to
this since the very first you made it
and and and again I I'm I'm asking for a
little bit of Charity to not do the
apple and oranges yes Christianity
didn't land that scaling no no it took
centuries yeah right it took centuries
right and and so it's like
I'm
saying it's a little bit unfair to what
I'm talking about in some ways right
it's like I don't know and I'm certainly
not trying to found a religion and I
keep saying that uh but
I think we're making progress in scaling
this more and more I think there's
reason to believe that's the case and
it's certainly not centered on me
because I have deliberately made that
the case because no I don't think I see
any of that I I I I think I hope you're
not thinking that I suggesting that I
don't see any of that I'm it's mostly
I'm looking like I'm trying to to I'm
trying to let's say I want you to
because I feel like I this my this the
way that I that I'm presenting it I
think
that's the way I think and so I want you
to there's lots of resonance like I want
you to I want you to break what I'm
saying sometimes even like if you I'm
trying I'm hoping you can even like poke
holes in in this idea that in some ways
worship is necessary for this yeah so
that's the primary proposition and it's
so like what I'm trying to get at is uh
because I mean
um you've got the practices till it
you've got ultimate concern for what's
ultimate in the and they're they're
they're very much about communing not
just communicating they're very much
about like the the sensing of the leap
to the higher level
um they're they're they're they're
they're they're very much about a a
sense of like
uh you know of of of radical religio
connecting grammar to grammar I've been
making that argument and some of the
talk so there's definitely awe and
sacredness and there's definitely
celebration people are sharing about how
so there's I feel like and then there's
the scalability issue I get that and
I've tried to respond to that I feel
like there's something else you're
trying to put your finger on and worship
that I'm I'm not getting and that's
where you want that's where you're
making your and I mean this as a friend
that's where you're making your stand
and I want to get clear on that no no
that's definitely I think in some ways
that's where
uh in the sense that I do see
like I do see the the worship part as
being crucial
to how things hold together yeah right
and I see that
um not just worship like true worship
let's say to God but I see celebration I
use the word celebration that you know
when you do something or you're moving
towards a goal you're you're necessarily
to some extent celebrating the thing
that you're moving towards right you
you're elevating it above other possible
things you're doing aspirational yeah
there you go that's a that's an
interesting that's an interesting way of
thinking about it and so at a micro
scale you you uh you know let's say
you're you're just you're just how can I
say this you're just walking towards the
door well that is a little ritual that
is recognizing something as good and is
lifting it up above all the other other
things you could do and is moving
towards it right so it's like it's a
little form of Celebration so but this
but but then the idea is that in order
for that to bind more it has to go
higher go higher obviously right but I
was trying to so going through the doors
relevance realization yeah right right
and then I was trying to say but you get
to a place where relevance realization
realizes that it's irrelevant in order
to give you the proper stance towards
ultimate and it has to give itself up
now that sounds to me like a radical
prioritization a radical lifting up of
of the no thickness of of what's of
Ultimate Reality of the inexhaust like
isn't that wouldn't that I no I totally
agree but that I think that that that's
the stance that is
something like
that stance to stand in front of the no
thickness to stand in front of the
infinite and to just that's all you do
really there's nothing else you can do
except see not see it not or just make a
gesture towards it yeah Nicholas sakuza
is like as soon as you try and grab it
you fall into paradoxes and the
paradoxes that just frees your mind kind
of thing yeah I I totally get that
like
we might be just turning around in
circles at this point it's possible
because I mean I think that definitely
like we
every time we talk about this we push
each other further like and then I think
we reach the point where we might have
to think about it more on our own and
and keep going
okay so let me just bring it back to the
idea of the of the of the the problem of
the meaning crisis and the problem of
the home let's say the idea of the
spiritual home uh
is that
okay we come back to this idea of that
the thing that we celebrate in some ways
has to be our origin and in somehow some
ways has to be our Telos
and that we don't totally pick that no
if we don't get to decide what that is
completely it it's revealed to us you
know and even for people that have
conversion experiences they usually
don't it's not like they decided to
believe something right it's something
that that reveals itself it's the it's
this thing that revealed itself to us uh
and so
and I think that
that is again is like that is my worry
of any project now that tries to
like build something yes right to like
to create this new thing uh and that
it's fine to do that as long as it's all
the intermediary things right so like
for example you know I think Estuary is
great and I think that's wonderful but
if I if I heard Estuary trying to
replace let's say the church I don't
want to no not you and I don't know what
I'm using it then he's I'm looking at
you
then then I would then I would become I
would be like uh I don't think think you
have you don't have what it you don't
have what it takes to do that uh and so
it was funny Applause John Van dong is a
party uh and so I'm worried about all of
that like we talk about we talked about
certain people that because there's a
lot of that going on like there is yeah
and I'm I'm deeply opposed to that too
and I don't want to replace the church I
don't want to replace the mosque I don't
want to replace the synagogue so there's
a couple things here
um one is I think you might be right
about the death and resurrection of
Christianity and uh and and I think
I'm still very open to what that might
be and I try to keep open that's why I
keep in discussion with you so I want to
give you that
um but a lot of people
see the dying and that's all they see in
profound ways and then that's mixed up
with some very bad history
and the Christianity is not available to
them for that reason and could we
nevertheless help those people and
there's two possible responses one is a
nasty response is no do damn them to
hell or the other is well no they still
should be helped and however that turns
out well you know hopefully what is true
and good and beautiful will be at work
in that Saint Paul talks about capturing
every good thought yeah right right so
the second thing is
part of what I think is going on and I
hear this more in explicit explicated by
Paul is
well Christianity has this huge history
and that means it's been put through
lots of Trials and therefore it's more
trustworthy in a lot of ways I think
that's a very legitimate argument the
problem is that argument would undermine
you adopting Christianity at its origin
point
so there's there's a problem with that
argument it gets you very close to
performing a contradiction because
Christianity was premised on the fact no
no we can break from right the tradition
and so yeah I don't I really I mean
because I'm Orthodox I don't seem to
think I don't think that but that's
problematic but that that's the other
problem for me and you don't have this
problem and that's fine but I see the
claim that the Christian reads the
Jewish scriptures better than the Jewish
people yeah very problematic as most
Jews do so yeah and as most Christians
find the Islamic yes claim yeah yes
exactly exactly exactly that's a
legitimate concern yes yes so that's
that's that's that's how I would respond
yeah to that point
yeah so I I think we that we've pushed
hope very deeply
um and I think we've taught touched on
trust
uh quite well because
um trust is an interesting one for me
but I think you've given me a lot to
think about but I think one thing that
was still sort of
has been left implicitous like this
virtue of humility
and so
for us I mean the culture humility is
very hard to inventio or reinventio
because well think about the process
humiliation that's not a that's not a
positive word yeah that's a that's a
word of Devastation and destruction and
loss right
so what is it we need to do
to
and habilitate inhabit habit
rehabilitate humility well I think I
really I think that we have an
opportunity it's a little
it's annoying because it's a very
pressing opportunity is that we have we
have a tendency today to self name for
people who want to Auto originate yes
yes and when we see that we notice what
it does it creates a very strange it
creates a very strange instability when
people try to self name and you could
imagine that the image of self naming in
in the Bible the idea of taking the
Apple for ourselves or especially Babel
right the idea where we will build make
for ourselves a name we'll reach heaven
and make for ourselves a name that
doesn't work uh because of that because
of just the levels the how the how
reality works like you said for you to
be able to quantify anything the name
already has to be given yes for you to
be able to be able to calculate anything
the identity has already to be it has to
be already there yes right and so and so
that's that that's the scale like that
this relationship and so if you
understand that then humility is just
the proper stance in front of before
life which is that I cannot re I cannot
will myself into existence I have to
receive from Heaven I receive from above
received from the past receive from
tradition received from from that which
was that that is not me who I am and
without that I I can't you know I'll
just I'll just fragment and collapse and
then start to break apart that's really
good so first of all
part of what I'm hearing is
uh humility is an approach an
appropriately apprehensive appreciation
of the vertical yeah right something
like that an appropriate apprehension of
the vertical so you and like you
understand that much is being given and
it could also be this way too right what
what is like how the Earth gives and and
right right yeah well I mean that the
idea that body comes from also comes
from yeah from from outside so I think
that's that's very very powerful
two things
um humility seems to also be have within
it a recognition of one's false failures
infinitude
um that's the opposite of hubris so how
how that gets in and then thirdly how do
we not crush the fact that there is an
aspect and this is the existentialist
made a big deal of this and some of them
are Christians right that there's a big
aspect of us that is self-defining
self-interpreting and part of being you
being Jonathan is the way in which you
have right defined yourself and like
there is that's one of the ways in which
we're reliably different from other
organisms on the planet right so how do
first of all how how does the
recognition I'll just use finitude for
how does that fit into that and then how
how do we not Crush
that part of us that is appropriately
understood as our capacity for
self-definition so I would say the the
first one in terms of
in terms of of uh
of being humble and recognizing your
fault and all that one of the problems
the reason why that has been so diseased
in the past few centuries is I think
precisely because we don't think that
someone who really thinks they're
wretched usually doesn't have a problem
the problem is usually people who think
they're wretched but really think
they're not yeah yeah and so and so they
they have this perception of their
wretchedness but they think they should
be something else so because of that
they live they experience it as a kind
of Oppression and a kind of of of of
bitterness so there's but if you read it
if you read the great the great father
is like this sense of of being empty you
know and of seeing your faults if you
don't think you have you have much then
then all your faults just become
opportunities for you to get better like
that's all they are they're just
opportunities all your sins become
opportunities all your faults become
opportunities and again I'm not doing
that just so you know sometimes by that
most of the time but I can kind of see
that and I think that that the the the
the even the whole idea of self-esteem
that the modern West has developed
self-esteem has been a failure yeah I
mean no no seriously the empirical data
is self-esteem has been a failure
okay like if either either we say it's a
rational scientific project and we make
predictions and we then we get the
disconfirming evidence or we're playing
some game and of course the culture to a
large degree is playing some game right
um and I agree put that aside that if
you look at the data self-esteem has
been a mistake so but then the idea of
this of the self-naming or the
actualization I think that that can be
experienced uh as a self-transcendence
yes right but it's it's not
self-transcendence in the sense of just
picking yourself up by your bootstraps
and lifting yourself up it's the it's
it's very much like the idea of
following a leader right so someone
something appears to you as bright and
as beautiful and powerful and it pulls
you right it kind of kind of gives you
that that oomph to move to move into it
so you you obviously participate in that
but you don't have it in you yeah right
yeah right it's like there there are
there are things that are that are
guiding and pulling you whether it's
you know whether it's you're you're
playing Sport and there are sports
players before you that are superstars
and those examples are kind of moving
you forward and are aspirational yeah so
what I'm hearing is
and and I I'm going to bring in uh the
platonic thing about you know the
aspirational the appropriate
aspirational appreciation of the
vertical that is properly Binding
Together the finitude and the
Transcendent how's that for humility
yeah do you like that I think that's
fine yeah that's good yeah we can I
think humility
it's good that you bring up humility
because it's true that it's something
that most people think is uh horrible we
have a sense that that humble people are
weak uh but I you know there are
interesting stories of humility uh that
show the strength of humility and Saint
Francis of Assisi is a great example yes
there are many examples where he humbles
himself in a way that actually
example secretly raising himself above
everybody else he's not he's not doing
it but it's happening yeah you know by
the fact that he's lowering himself and
he's shaming everyone around around him
to a point where everybody recognizes
that he's the he's the master
so I'm not claiming to do this either
but yeah
um
I do is I mean this is sort of meta I
aspire to being
more humble because for me I want to
more
that what we just talk about that that
it's not the polls it's the polarity
right that that
aspiration appropriately aspirational
appreciation and appreciation means
understanding as well as valuing right
of the The Binding of the finite and the
Transcendent together
I want to
I Aspire not just want who cares about
my wants I aspire
to be in The Stance the orientation so
that the love of what is true and good
and beautiful can Row in me and for me
that is how I try to practice the
aspiration towards humility does that
land for you yeah
no I think that's great and I think that
that's and I I agree I think that
you do sometimes appear that's why some
people think you're kind of
christian-like because you
Christianity
light you can choose but no but that the
fact that you that you seem to have
taken up uh humility and agape and the
virtues that Christian recognize as
being that which leads towards the good
and because you often embody them you
know people see you and and are so I
mean are taken by by your by your stance
in life so yeah don't you agree some of
you yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
the the
Socrates is not my only Sage I have like
I said I have a symphony of sages and I
given what you just did I hope you'll
hear this in the right way Jesus is also
one of my sages and he will he will
always be that and I've wrestled with
that and I've come to but for at least
me at least now a place of Peace around
that um so if you're seeing that
um
I hope this isn't disrespectful some of
the credit goes to to Jesus for me some
of the credit also goes to satarta and
to Socrates but yes I want to give I
always like to give credit where credit
is due and so
um yeah uh
um I I I
value that I mean I've had a tortured
relationship at least early on and you
did too to some degree with Christianity
um and I have criticisms of it and I've
voiced some of them but
I always
you know it
at least
imaginably For Me Like Jesus is Alive in
me in that way I don't consider myself a
Christian because I think there's other
because I don't want to water down what
I have respect for Christianity I don't
want to water it down right I don't want
to you have specific claims about
history and and I I
right but I just want to give credit I
was brought up and then you know and
I've I've returned in some ways to
I hope a right relationship Within
Myself with Christianity through tillic
and who you know interacting with uh
with a whole bunch of thinkers David
should learn who I've now met and you
and Paul
um and I hope
um
I feel
that there's been a lot of movement
within me so that
um
I can hopefully I'm invoking hope I can
invoke hopefully at times
um
let that part of Me Shine through in a
way that is valuable to other people
that's great yeah
so how much time do we have we should I
think we should end there yeah I think
we're done thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you